mariah is taking us inside our fashion
treasure trove that's a true vision of
love we are in my closet right now in my
New York apartment I don't think I did
it intentionally but there probably is a
sense of drama and a sense of grad
with custom-made gold leaf and white
wooden floors Mariah's massive closet
sits inside her 12,000 square-foot
Tribeca penthouse I have a lot of
different dresses position just because
there they are
lining the walls from floor to ceiling
color-coordinated rows of her signature
stilettos but all right here's the only
shoes that matter I don't know I can't
believe these are my shoes Mariah's
collection of lingerie is also
impressive so much so it has its own
closet inside her closet dolly I walk
around and like more of like a slip
dress with a crowbar it and the boost
days and stuff might be more for private
time other hidden treasures a 1960s
compact from Marilyn Monroe which Mimi
bought in an auction for
$34,000 this P Birkin bag a gift from
boxing champ Floyd Mayweather and lots
of shades I try to see like what works
on my face because I chipmunk cheeks the
Divas domain isn't off-limits for twins
rock and roll in fact the six year olds
already have an appreciation for the
finer things
[Applause]
[Music]
that's been babies use em Laura
[Music]